governing requires a different set of
skills than warring and after two
decades in the wilderness fighting the
taliban now faced the mundane but
challenging tasks of keeping the lights
on traffic running and the banks open
the new taliban finance minister knows
how to raise money to buy weapons but
appears poorly equipped to coordinate
fiscal and monetary policy the banks are
limiting withdrawals inflation is
skyrocketing unemployment is high and
people are starving dw's nick connolly
has more
cueing to join another queue behind the
barbed wire
to have a chance of seeing their cash
these afghans all got up at 3 a.m 3 a.m
the day before that is at best they'll
be able to withdraw some 20 000 afghani
or 200 euros
with afghanistan's foreign reserves
frozen the taliban administration has
chosen to paralyze the banking system in
an attempt to stop hard currency
flooding out of the country in the
process they've brought the whole
economy to a grinding halt
i'm just waiting for my salary i don't
know the future no one is okay everyone
is depressed here in afghanistan i think
the situation is escalating day by day
no one dares challenge them for now but
afghanistan's new taliban rulers know
full well that tensions are rising as
ordinary afghans cash reserves run out
and new jobs prove almost impossible to
come by
these tradesmen tell us they haven't
worked in weeks
before i would only work as a carpenter
now i'll clean toilets if i have to we
might end up starving or killing
ourselves and the taliban will cut your
hand off if you steal
[Music]
in a country where nearly all basic food
stuffs from rice to oil and flour are
imported
closed banks and currency controls mean
rising prices and scarcity
this shopkeeper tells us that prices for
basics have gone up by at least 50 in
the past month
people who used to buy big bags of sugar
are now looking for a one kilo
alternative one liter of oil instead of
five liters and the people who could
only afford one liter before are now
asking for even smaller sizes
daily turnover is already down by three
quarters and if things don't change soon
he tells us he plans to close the store
the baker next door he says has already
given up and left the country in search
of a better life in europe
[Music]
faced with soaring prices and a dearth
of jobs many in kabul are selling
whatever they have left to put food on
the table their pots their pans and even
their beds
it's one thing for the fortunate few
setting up with visas in their pockets
waiting to leave
but a very different proposition for the
vast majority with no plan b
six weeks after the taliban take over
here in kabul an economic crisis here in
afghanistan is still far from over with
banks limiting withdrawals to just 200
euros per week and businesses paralyzed
we spoke to ordinary afghans who've told
us that they're at rock bottom as their
cash savings run out
one father of seven told me that he had
just ten afghani or 10 euros sent to his
name and even that was borrowed his
story is just one of millions as
afghanistan now faces the very real
prospect of hunger and malnutrition
we'll have more from nick connolly in
just a moment
now when we talk about economic collapse
that kind of environment often leads to
higher crime remember one of the other
men nick spoke to said he's so desperate
to feed his family he has considered
stealing but he won't he said because he
doesn't want his hands cut off
that's the kind of justice the taliban
has announced they're bringing back
a signal of where things are headed can
be seen in the western city of herat
where taliban fighters gunned down four
alleged kidnappers during a shootout
they were suspected of abducting a
businessman and his son
taliban authorities then made a show of
their brand of justice just a warning
some of you may find the following
report upsetting
in the heart of herat
a gruesome spectacle meant to shock an
awe
the corpse of an alleged criminal
hanging
from a crane
pinned to the man is a note that reads
this is the punishment for kidnapping
it's a signal to criminals says this
taliban commander that they are not safe
and a foreboding sign to the world that
brutal punishments are back in
afghanistan
executions and amputations will be
restored
with one caveat not supported by this
display
that they won't take place in public
that's according to mola tarabi a senior
taliban figure he told the associated
press that no one will tell us what our
laws should be we will follow islam and
we will make our laws on the quran
in the capital kabul crime was a huge
problem before the recent taliban
takeover
the collapsing war economy led to a wave
of robberies and drug related killings
many residents have said off-camera that
they fear the taliban's ruthlessness
but on camera it's another story
it's a good thing others will learn a
lesson from it
i believe that what they're doing about
catching thieves and punishing them is
very good for the law and order
situation
but they should not do this without some
legal recourse
but that's an expectation the taliban
appear nowhere close to respecting
despite assurances
to the contrary
joining us is dw's nick connolly in
kabul nick i suppose it's too much from
the taliban to expect that this kind of
punishment they're warning about
executions amputations and hangings take
place with any due process or court
proceedings i mean has the country's
courts been completely dismantled
melissa this is a country in flux the
old system has gone or at least ground
to halt and the new system hasn't been
introduced and it's very patchy across
the country so those kind of killings
that you saw in that report have been
reported from places like herrera mazar
sharif less so here in kabul um i think
the taliban is are just at a point now
of trying to somehow unify their control
across the country and don't have a
handle on things like judicial procedure
we have heard from them that sharia law
will be their priority going forward and
that takes precedence over other forms
of jurisprudence they are though
seemingly very worried about vigilante
killings there was an edict from top
leaders saying that taliban fighters are
not allowed to take revenge even on
people who had um fought against them or
even killed members of their family that
that would be punished severely um if it
were to happen so a real fear seemingly
here in kabul from the taliban
leadership of a loss of control and of
course what sharia is is open to
interpretation depending on who you ask
now going back to your report looking at
the bank run and the economic collapse
of the country can you tell us a little
bit about how it feels to be in kabul
walking around right now i mean are
people running out of cash to a point
that they're starting
to barter instead of buy things with
money
well definitely you see a lot of people
looking for work a lot of worried faces
a lot of people who haven't been able to
work in
over a month and even if they have might
not have been paid for it government
hospital schools state employees not
receiving anything and people just
saying that their reserves of cash are
running out even if they have money in
the bank they're just not able to get it
um people you know reducing uh the money
they spend trying to kind of make it
last longer and asking themselves is
there a future for them in this country
so a lot of tension when you go and find
tradesmen who are out looking for a job
as soon as someone turns out turns up in
a car offering a day's work a scrum of
people desperate to work for far less
than they would have been willing to
work just a month ago and at a time
where prices have skyrocketed because
all the essentials come from abroad and
have to be paid for in dollars by those
suppliers so a real
crunch here for ordinary afghans and no
real prospect of that situation being
resolved in a hurry
the people need money the government
also needs money the taliban
needs a lot of money if they want to run
a country where will they get that i
mean will it be from selling more opium
what are their options
that's the million dollar question and
they don't seem to be many good options
on the table as for opium for drugs they
have said that they are going to try and
clamp down on this and now autumn is
traditionally the
poppy sowing season the new crop to be
sown now and they say they're going to
try and reduce that having said that
their attempts to do that in the 90s
backfired on them because they weren't
able to provide
ordinary villagers an alternative crop
that would provide anywhere near the
same income as opium does um given that
that you know the international help
that supported the previous government
by some estimates the previous
government was dependent on
international mainly western aid for up
to 70 of its income there doesn't really
seem to be any game in town no real
economic plan uh visible now we've
talked to business people who say that
the taliban so far have yet to explain
to them what's going to happen and how
they're going to
make this country
a place where the millions of young
people here can find a living
and the taliban has pledged that they
will
try to get rid of opium production so
it's going to be very tricky for them
you mentioned foreign aid and that has
generally stopped we're hearing that
russia and china providing some aid do
you see the possibility of aid foreign
aid returning
well there's significant skepticism as
to the real intentions of the chinese
and russians if they're really willing
to match the sums that were coming in
previously they've been known in the
past to make
you know good pr efforts but not really
to be willing to provide the same
volumes of money in the long run as for
the largely western a that used to prop
up the government here in kabul well
there's obviously great
concern in western capitals that that
money will just support the taliban and
help them to
expand their control of this country so
attempts to try and ring fence that kind
of finance for medical care for
education for direct humanitarian
intervention and somehow prevent that
money from falling into the hands of the
taliban authorities but precious little
um plan or idea how that can really be
put into practice and how really they
can do that without yeah giving the
taliban here in kabul a lifeline
nick connolly thank you so much for
joining us
and here are some more developments in
afghanistan the mayor of kabul is
warning the city could soon be without
water the shortage has been sparked by a
drought and made worse by the conflict
a taliban minister has called on afghans
to stay in the country rather than go
abroad repeating the claim that there is
an amnesty for those who used to work
for the western-backed government
and the taliban have banned barber shops
in the south from shaving or trimming
beards saying their edict is in line
with islamic law
you